[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 sur TV
78 actualités infos pratiques et idées
de sortie pour bien démarrer la soirée
dans les Yvelines voici le programme de
ce lundi 12 juin
une après-midi dédiée à la création
d'entreprise la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des Yvelines la propose
demain à Versailles l'occasion pour les
porteurs de projets de tout savoir sur
le sujet Frédéric Dassonville
responsable du pôle création et
formalités à la CCI 78 et notre invité
pour en parler nous ferons le point
également avec lui sur la situation de
l'entrepreneuriat dans le département
un vice champion du monde de football à
Verneuil-sur-Seine Matteo Guen Douzi
s'est rendu dans la ville il y a
quelques jours pour un événement
particulier un terrain a été rebaptisé à
son nom c'est l'hommage rendu par la
municipalité aux jeunes joueurs qui a
débuté le football dans la commune le
milieu de l'Olympique de Marseille a
même été scolarisé au collège Jean Zay
et puis dans la partie sport retour sur
les finales nationales de gymnastique
UFOLEP le complexe sportif Pierre MASO
de Saint-Cyr-l'École et le gymnase du
Levant de Fontenay-le-Fleury ont
accueilli 2000 athlètes durant tout le
weekend un objectif pour eux le titre de
champion de France
et ce sera dans les résultats à retenir
du week-end avec vous Nicolas dandry
bonsoir bonsoir journaliste de la
rédaction de Télé 78 préposés au sport
depuis quelques semaines en attendant le
retour de Mickaël el midoro en plateau
vous allez nous parler des résultats
sports du week-end vous allez nous
parler de quoi ce soir on va parler de
football parce qu'il y avait à la fois
le deuxième tour de la Coupe de France
en football ça concerne les clubs de
régionale et de départementale je vais
vous parler aussi de rugby avec le club
de Chevreuse on va faire un bilan et se
projeter sur la saison prochaine en
Fédérale de la CGT pour Chevreuse la
saison très bonne on va voir avec le
coach Stéphane doucher qui est notre
invité et puis je vais vous parler aussi
des finales du championnat de France de
golf c'est de en UNSS et bien ce sont
des collégiens qui ont joué ce
championnat de France les finales
avaient lieu jeudi dernier et c'est nos
invités d'ailleurs ils sont champions de
France imaginez-vous les collégiens du
lycée international de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye international ça
va être la maternelle au lycée
exactement et alors il y a Maya la
Melvin Niels et Aurelio qui ont décroché
le championnat de France le titre de
champion de France excellence en golf on
va revenir sur cette compétition avec
leur professeur le professeur Coffe
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir heureux d'être
avec vous pour partager ce bel événement
et puis le trophée il est là sur le
plateau avec tout à fait
uranil aussi un des un des vainqueurs
la finale face à Capbreton ils étaient
redoutables un Capbreton vous aviez une
crainte au début de ce match sur le
papier c'était bien plus fort que nous
et des individualités vraiment très très
poussées et puis ce qu'a fait la
différence c'est que nous on a joué en
équipe je pense et voilà ça c'est ça a
bien tourné on leur a mis l'impression
et on est heureux de conserver le titre
dans les Yvelines terre d'accueil de ces
championnats de France donc voilà c'est
vraiment une chouette chose on reviendra
sur cette finale et sur cette
compétition Grégory tout à l'heure UNSS
juste pour les téléspectateurs union
nationale du sport scolaire avec ce
championnat de France qui se dérouler la
semaine dernière dans les Yvelines
comment se porte la création
d'entreprises c'est la question qu'on
posera aussi qu'on se posera dans la
première partie du 7 8 ce sera avec vous
Frédéric d'Assonville bonsoir bonsoir
Grégory merci à vous d'être présent avec
nous j'aurais dans les titres vous êtes
responsable du pôle création et
formalités d'entreprise à la CCI
versailles-yvelines et vous organisez
demain dans les locaux de la CCI une
après-midi dédiée à la création
d'entreprise on va en parler tout à
l'heure en une phrase la situation est
bonne pour la création d'entreprise on
aura l'occasion tout à l'heure détaillé
mais ce que les voyants sont au vert la
situation n'est pas mauvaise on a une
belle dynamique entrepreneuriale on se
début d'année 2023 il a une dernière
c'est une année record pour la création
était également une bonne année
effectivement
cette année et puis j'accueille enfin
Céline Charles bonsoir de la rédaction
de TV 78 avec vous les actualités
informations Yves linoise du jour c'est
avec vous dans un instant restez avec
nous juste avant on va jeter un petit
coup d'œil aux prévisions météo de
demain
après le temps orageux de ces dernières
heures le soleil et le ciel clair
reviennent demain il va faire chaud dès
le matin dans le département compté 19
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et 18 à Houdan
et Rambouillet et même 20 degrés à
Versailles elle l'après-midi les
conditions ne changent pas les
températures seront proches des 30
degrés il fera 29 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 28 sur les secteurs de
Versailles ou dans et Rambouillet et
demain nous fêterons les Antoine le
point à présent sur l'actualité du jour
dans les Yvelines
et on commence les lignes avec cette
information une place au nom de Michel
PERICARD a officiellement été inauguré à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye la ville a décidé
de rendre hommage à ce célèbre
Saint-Germain en donnant son nom à une
place au cœur de l'écoquartier de la
lisière Pereire alors député de 1988 à
1999 vice-président de l'Assemblée
nationale dans le gouvernement d'Alain
Juppé mais surtout mère de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pendant plus de 20
ans Michel Péricard était un homme pas
passionné par sa ville il était entre
autre précurseur des journées sans
voiture et créateur de la zone
piétonnière c'est maintenant son fils
Arnaud PERICARD qui est à la tête de la
ville Gérald de Darmanin dans les
Yvelines ça s'est passé vendredi à la
direction zonale des CRS de
Vélizy-Villacoublay oui le ministre de
l'Intérieur s'est rendu pour célébrer
les 10 ans du service de la protection
de la police nationale le SDLP il
regroupe 1471 agents qui ont pour
mission d'assurer la sécurité de
nombreuses personnalités publiques comme
les membres du gouvernement les chefs
d'État mais aussi les personnes menacées
comme des journalistes ou des magistrats
le service s'occupe également de la
sécurité des grands sommets ou des
visites d'État alors pour l'occasion une
cérémonie a été donnée sur place le
ministre appuy rencontrer de nombreux
agents qu'il a tenu d'ailleurs à
remercier pour leur travail il a
également rendu hommage à se tomber dans
l'exercice de leur fonction 700 plus de
700 habitants de Trappes se sont rendus
ce week-end à la salle Richelieu à Paris
pour assister à une représentation de
l'Avare de Molière oui une journée
inoubliable a été rendu possible grâce à
un partenariat historique entre la ville
de trappes et la Comédie Française une
idée qui est venue à l'origine d'Alain
Degois fondateur de la troupe Déclic
Théâtre attrapes et qui est devenu
réalité avec la pluie des élus de la
municipalité alors pour l'occasion 15
bus ont été affrétés au départ de
Trappes les habitants se sont rendus
dans le prestigieux théâtre parisien qui
leur était réservé et ont pu assister à
la représentation de la pièce offerte
par l'institution culturelle objectif de
l'opération démocratisée l'accès à la
culture notamment chez les plus jeunes
le partenariat se poursuit pendant trois
ans avec d'autres représentations mais
aussi des déplacements de la troupe dans
les établissements scolaires et
puisqu'on parle de théâtre il y a un
appel à projet qui est lancé jusqu'au 30
juin par le groupe des 21 dans la région
et c'est d'ailleurs un groupe qui réunit
des directeurs de structures
francilienne de proximité le Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et la ferme de
Bel et bag Guyancourt en font partie
alors si vous êtes artiste et que la
thématique du vivant vous parle et vous
inspire vous pouvez proposer votre
projet sur le groupe des 20 théâtres
dans ce cirque music ou encore théâtre
le projet peut-être pluridisciplinaire
mais doit durer maximum deux heures et
au moins deux artistes devront être
présents sur scène le lauréat aura droit
à un apport en coproduction de 20 000
euros et une tournée dans les lieux du
réseau d'environ 15 dates pour la saison
2024 2025 la date de fin de candidature
est fixée au 30 juin prochain on termine
avec un drôle de duel qui s'est déroulé
ce week-end vous n'êtes peut-être pas
sans savoir que les villes de
Toussus-le-Noble et châteaux forts
partagent un code postal et bien pour se
le disputer symboliquement les deux
communes organisé samedi une journée de
jeu intervillages les habitants ont pu
défendre leur ville en participant à
plusieurs épreuves ont retrouvé par
exemple la course à ski la course en
toile de jute en relais mais aussi la
brouette humaine ou encore le penalty à
l'aveugle un beau programme alors qui a
gagné et bien réponse prochainement sur
TV 78 en vous expliquera plus en détail
cet événement insolite en reportage
salut en tout cas nos invités ça fait
penser un peu à Intervilles
de cette émission pas du tout si c'était
plutôt sympathique quand j'étais enfant
de regarder les vachettes etc c'était
très c'était très sympa en tout cas
château fort on a essayé de reproduire
la bonne recette et on aura l'occasion
d'y revenir comme le disait Céline dans
un prochain reportage merci beaucoup
d'ailleurs pour ces informations comme
d'habitude si vous aussi près de chez
vous vous êtes témoin d'une actualité
qui vous fait réagir et n'hésitez pas à
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
tout savoir sur l'entrepreneuriat la
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
versailles-yvelines organisent son
après-midi de la création d'entreprise
ça se passe demain de 13h30 à 18h30 dans
les locaux de la CCI à Versailles avenue
de Paris et cette organisé en
partenariat avec Banque Populaire Val de
France BP Crédit Agricole
Île-de-France Matmut et Pôle emploi
Versailles je le disais on en parle avec
vous Frédéric Dassonville vous êtes le
responsable du pôle création est
formalité d'entreprise à la CCI
Versailles oui une première question
pourquoi organiser cet après-midi de la
création d'entreprise quels sont les
objectifs alors les objectifs en fait
c'est de pouvoir expliquer à toute
personne qui s'intéresse à la création
dans d'entreprise de pouvoir lui
expliquer quels sont les différents les
parcours qui sont à réaliser pardon et
les différentes étapes essentielles pour
réussir son projet et ça leur permettra
aussi de rencontrer tous les acteurs qui
leur permettront vraiment de pouvoir
avancer sur leurs projets et de
concrétiser leurs rêves entrepreneurial
c'est difficile quand on est employé ou
même demandeur d'emploi de se mettre
dans un statut de créateur d'entreprise
sera d'ailleurs je pense je crois à l'un
des l'un des ateliers demain mais c'est
difficile de faire cette transition
c'est difficile bah en fait il y a tout
un tout un état d'esprit qu'il faut
qu'il faut faire évoluer et évoluer
lorsque l'on est salarié bon voilà on a
l'entreprise qui qui peut porter les
salariés sur un certain nombre de sujets
alors que là on est son propre moteur
pour pouvoir avancer sur le projet et
faire en sorte qu'il soit rentable et le
faire vivre tout simplement à qui
s'adresse cet après-midi du coup c'est à
tous ceux qui souhaitent porter un
projet d'entreprise absolument c'est à
partir du moment où on est même un
simple porteur d'idées c'est à dire que
l'on réfléchit à un projet de création
d'entreprise on peut déjà venir à cet
après-midi de la création pour sa
culture et pour pour voir comment est-ce
qu'on peut avancer dans dans son projet
donc on soit un simple porteur d'idées
ou déjà bien avancé dans son projet on
peut tout à fait participer à cet
après-midi
vous aviez peut-être une question un mot
sur les domaines aujourd'hui les
domaines d'activité dans lesquels les
créateurs d'entreprise s'engagent c'est
souvent les mêmes thématiques qui
reviennent ou alors où il y a quelque
chose une est-ce qu'il y a une rupture
avec le covid peut-être une rupture
alors en fait on a quand même sur les
les les
créations d'entreprise environ 70%
d'activité de service qui sont créés
environ 20% de son disgridité des
activités de commerce c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui compte tenu des
problématiques d'inflation etc les
activités de commerce sont beaucoup plus
difficiles à déployer et effectivement
avec la crise covid voilà les achats sur
internet ont pris ont pris quand même le
le pli sur ça et donc c'est beaucoup
plus complexe à ce niveau là donc les
activités de service en plus en plus le
vent en poupe d'hiroun vous parlez d'un
phénomène d'inflation on va rentrer un
peu dans la technique économique Grégory
mais on voit aussi les taux d'intérêt
augmenter alors il y a des difficultés
sur le marché de l'immobilier puisque
ceux qui veulent acheter un bien
immobilier du mal à accéder au crédits
qu'en est-il concernant les chefs
d'entreprise qui n'ont pas forcément de
fonds propres pour engager une création
d'entreprise est-ce que les banques
aujourd'hui font confiance aux créateurs
d'entreprises les banques font toujours
confiance aux porteurs de porteurs de
projets d'entreprise effectivement les
taux ont aussi augmenté un tout petit
peu mais il existe en fait des
dispositifs qu'on appelle des frais
d'honneur qui sont des prêts à taux zéro
et sans garantie qui permettent en fait
aux porteurs de projets d'accroître son
son apport en tout cas de compléter son
apport personnel et donc de faciliter la
levée de dettes bancaire et donc demain
nous aurons la présence d'un certain
nombre de ces associations pour ben
voilà faciliter encore une fois le
lancement des projets et justement qui
pourront-ils rencontrer sur place pour
cet après-midi de la création
d'entreprise pour rencontrer alors on a
pas mal de pas mal d'opérateurs
puisqu'on a justement ces structures ces
associations qui font du financement de
prêt d'honneur on a par exemple le
Réseau Entreprendre le réseau initiative
qui qui sera là nous avons nos
partenaires bancaires que vous avez cité
tout à l'heure nous avons des avocats
des experts comptables on a évidemment
le Pôle emploi qui est un qui est un
opérateur important pour favoriser la
création d'entreprise nous avons aussi
des structures comme comme BP et des
entreprises pardon et des associations
d'accompagnement qui elles les porteurs
de projets à monter les business plan et
à
aller chercher de l'argent en fait voilà
pour revenir sur le sujet que j'évoquais
vous êtes pas inquiet par rapport à ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui inflation un
ralentissement peut-être de l'économie
inquiet on peut on peut toujours être
inquiet mais il faut il faut être
positif dans le monde de la de la
création d'entreprise et effectivement
on peut on peut se poser un certain
nombre de questions liées au coût
d'achat des matières des matières
premières qui augmentent vraiment le
coût de l'énergie aussi qui est
important mais on essaie quand même de
trouver des solutions pour que les
structures puissent se monter et même si
on a un tout petit peu d'inquiétude on
essaie vraiment de pousser les gens vers
la création et là où je veux aller aussi
c'est on a eu des chiffres quand même
record avec la création d'entreprise en
2022 suite au covid il y a eu un
phénomène aussi de rattrapage par
rapport au covid aujourd'hui est-ce que
c'est chiffre records se confirment
va-t-on vers de nouveaux records ou
finalement il y a un ralentissement de
la création
sont plutôt ouvert en tout cas la
situation est plutôt bonne création
d'entreprise sur les Yvelines on a eu
6500 créations créations sur le sur le
premier trimestre ce qui confirme la
tendance de 2022 où on était
effectivement sur une année record on
pourrait être sur
25026000 ou 27000 créations
d'entreprises à la à la fin de l'année
donc la tendance est bonne mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de création
d'entreprises et de micro-entreprises
qui représentent quand même le corpus le
plus important sur les créations donc
voilà donc oui moi je pense qu'il y a il
y a quand même un vrai engouement pour
l'entrepreneuriat et aujourd'hui les les
personnes sont très intéressées par tout
ça donc a priori Chris covid et très
dernièrement la crise en l'Ukraine qui a
on l'a dit a pu agir sur l'augmentation
des décharges ça freine pas les les
porteurs de projets je pense qu'ils
essaient de préparer beaucoup plus
précisément leurs projets ça veut pas
dire qu'avant c'était pas le cas bien
évidemment mais voilà maintenant les
dispositifs d'accompagnement permettent
aux porteurs de projet d'intégrer
vraiment c'est dimension de difficultés
financières et donc du coup il y a pas
il y a pas de frein vraiment lié à ce
contexte économique et international
comment justement la CCI dans ce
contexte un peu contraint
accompagne-t-elle les porteurs de
projets comment se matérialise on va
dire cet accompagnement alors nous avons
des dispositifs d'accompagnement
collectif à travers des formations
notamment le 5 jours pour entreprendre
ou le dispositif qui s'appelle start
entrepreneur donc ils sont des
dispositifs collectifs et on a également
des accompagnements individuels à
travers des dispositifs qui sont
co-financés par la Région
Île-de-France et également par l'Europe
qui s'appelle entrepreneur leader dans
lequel le bénéficiaire peut
avoir environ 10 une bonne dizaine
d'heures d'accompagnement individuels
pour monter son business plan valider
son modèle économique et donc aller
demander des financements et valider son
projet donc pour valider son projet
d'entreprise alors demain on le précise
il y aura différents ateliers on a
commencé à les évoquer il y aura
notamment un atelier sur les grandes
étapes les étapes clés pour créer son
entreprise très concrètement quelles
sont les quels sont-elles ces grandes
étapes on en saura un peu plus demain
alors en fait les grandes étapes de
l'entreprise c'est validé déjà ce qu'on
appelle l'adéquation homme projet
ensuite réaliser une étude de marché
pour être sûr qu'il y a un vrai besoin
et un vrai marché ensuite travailler sur
la partie juridique de l'entreprise et
enfin transformer tous ces aspects là en
chiffres et donc préparer un business
plan financier qui permettra voilà de
définir quelle est la rentabilité du
projet et on arrive malheureusement à la
fin de cet entretien pour en savoir plus
rendez-vous demain à la CCI Versailles
avoir toutes les informations s'afficher
pour cet après-midi de la création
d'entreprises donc 13h30 18h30 l'adresse
des locaux de la CCI 21 23 avenue de
Paris il faut ce qu'il faut s'inscrire
avant de avant de venir les inscriptions
sont clauses depuis la fin de depuis la
fin de matinée mais néanmoins vous
pouvez tout à fait venir même si vous
n'êtes pas inscrit donc voilà vous
arrivez et puis on vous orientera il y a
pas de souci donc c'est gratuit oui oui
c'est totalement gratuit c'est
totalement gratuit donc vous pouvez
venir demain même si vous n'êtes pas
inscrit il y a aucun problème on vous
accueille avec grand plaisir merci
Frédéric Dassonville d'être venu en
parler en plateau responsable du pôle
création et formalités d'entreprise à la
CCI Versailles Yvelines et on va ouvrir
à présent une page sport dans le 7 8
[Musique]
et je vais vous redonner la main Nicolas
on peut avoir 24 ans et déjà avoir un
stade à son nom oui effectivement le
terrain d'honneur du complexe sportif
François Pons de Verneuil-sur-Seine a
été rebaptisé Matteo Guendouzi la
cérémonie se tenait mercredi 7 juin le
footballeur de l'OM vice Champion du
Monde 2022 avec les Bleus au Qatar a
effectuer ses premiers pas de
footballeurs dans la commune qui a tenu
à lui rendre hommage l'occasion
également d'échanger avec les jeunes du
club vernolien le reportage de Grégory
canalet et William Morel
[Applaudissements]
un stade en hommage à ce petit de la
ville de venu grand le terrain d'honneur
du complexe sportif de
Verneuil-sur-Seine porte désormais le
nom de Matteo gain Douzi joueur de
l'Olympique de Marseille c'est pourtant
bien au PSG que le natif de Poissy a
débuté le football pensionnaire de la
préformation du club parisien
l'international français a été hébergé à
Verneuil et évoluait sur les terrains de
la commune il a même été élève au
collège Jean Zay j'y suis resté pendant
trois années donc j'ai fait ma cinquième
quatrième troisième ici au collège et
bah sur ces terrains c'est là où on
s'entraînait pareil pendant trois
saisons avec la avec la préformation
donc moi ça avait ça fait quoi 9 10 ans
maintenant donc pas mal de très bons
souvenirs qui qui reviennent et à 24
heures avoir un installation c'est quand
même quelque chose de très beau et j'en
suis vraiment très fier le footballeur a
également reçu la médaille de la ville
devant 150 invités la municipalité a
souhaité ainsi valoriser le parcours de
ce jeune vernolien ça a été presque deux
ans de travail pour pouvoir monter cette
journée évidemment il a un agenda sur
Charger mais surtout il y avait plein de
questions qui se posaient sur comment on
le faisait comment on organiser on a dû
passer une délibération au conseil
municipal et je me réjouis vraiment que
la majorité est portée ce projet afin de
donner des étoiles dans les yeux des
enfants
plus tard
de l'année
une après-midi du 7 juin 2023 dont les
jeunes du club se souviendront longtemps
Matteo Guendouzi a assisté à leur
entraînement pendant une petite heure
c'est un très bel hommage effectivement
pour Ben pour le club pour lui-même
avoir son monde dans son club d'origine
c'est c'est exceptionnel il m'a sauté
plein de bien pour l'avenir bien
travailler à l'école et de continuer le
foot si ça me plaît franchement j'ai été
ému c'était quelque chose que je pense
qu'il va marquer toute ma vie et
franchement ça a été un moment
incroyable l'occasion donc d'échanger
avec les footballeurs en herbe et de se
prêter ensuite à l'exercice de la séance
de dédicace ça fait extrêmement plaisir
parce que tu les vois avec le sourire tu
les vois avec la banane je les ai vu ce
matin au collège aussi c'était vraiment
tous heureux donc s'ils peuvent avoir
des des exemples pas que moi mais
d'autres mais d'autres joueurs ou
d'autres personnes c'est vraiment
quelque chose de beau pour que continuer
d'avancer dans dans le futur
l'après-midi c'est conclu par un match
de football pas de gaine Douzi sur le
terrain qui jouait les coachs pour cette
fois mais les jeunes n'avaient bien sûr
qu'un nom à la bouche
dans le 7 8 avec de nouveau invités qui
nous ont rejoint notamment Stephen
Douchet bonsoir entraîneur du Chevreuse
Rugby Club avec vous dans un stand à
revenir sur cette belle saison pour
Chevreuse une montée en Fédérale 3 aussi
une présence bien sûr dans les dans les
phases finales un petit un peu un
premier mot sur cette saison comment la
qualifier alors tout d'abord ça a été il
y avait plusieurs objectifs il y avait
l'objet un objectif sportif mais pas
seulement il y avait aussi un objectif
de redonner toute la place au rugby dans
la vallée de Chevreuse Parce que le
rugby n'avait de Chevreuse c'est une
institution et puis bah je pense que
c'est réussi parce que si le dimanche
vous venez à Chevreuse quand on jouait
bah le village était vide tout le monde
était au stade donc je pense qu'on a
redonné une âme vraiment au club pour
les 20 ans du titre de champion de
France de club cet objectif là est
validé on va revenir sur cette belle
saison en fin d'édition tout à l'heure
avec vos côtés il y a toujours Olivier
coffre professeur d'EPS au lycée
international de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
on a été aussi rejoint par Niels
nilsgard c'est bien ça garde s on
prononce le S final bonsoir puisque on
va revenir avec vous et avec vous aussi
Nicolas sur ce titre on disait de
champion de France de golf UNSS ça se
passait la semaine dernière
effectivement on va déjà expliqué ce qui
était cette compétition ils étaient 28
collèges venus de métropole de Mayotte
et de la Réunion 124 joueurs réunis la
semaine dernière au golf de l'île de
loisirs des Boucles de Seine moi sur un
moisson pardon la compétition a commencé
mardi dernier et les finales ce sont
déroulées le jeudi 8 juin une
compétition avec trois catégories
championnats excellence championnat
établissement championnat sport partagé
et on écoute Kid DIN Albert directrice
départementale de l'unssd Yvelines qui
nous explique et bien le principe de ce
championnat
d'excellence c'est pour des élèves qui
sont très bien classés puisque j'ai un
index inférieur à 36 le championnat
d'équipe établissement c'est un
championnat réservé à tous les élèves
Open et donc c'est des élèves qui
pratiquent la S régulièrement mais qu'on
va forcément une pratique derrière en
club et on a le championnat de sport
partagé qui a 8 équipes et ça c'est
assez remarquable en UNSS c'est une
équipe de deux élèves un qui va être
valide un en situation de handicap qui
vont travailler toute l'année pour jouer
ensemble et qui vont se qualifier qui
vont jouer aujourd'hui leur finale et
pour le championnat excellence et bien
c'est les collégiens du lycée
international de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
qui l'ont emporté regardé ces images
c'est une compétition pour moi ça
représente
c'est un prénom une chose toute nouvelle
pour moi
oui alors on va peut-être regarder
l'extrait dont vous parliez Nicolas
l'extrait donc la joie c'est ça au
moment de la remise des trophées
international de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
sont quasiment domicile un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour le Collège
International de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
académie de Versailles dans les Yvelines
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très beau souvenir Nicolas et avant de
revenir sur la finale on va parler des
premiers jours mardi mercredi comment ça
s'est passé ces deux premiers jours Nice
le premier jour on avait joué contre une
équipe qui était un peu moins beaucoup
moins forte que nous et ils ont pas
gagné au Lama alors que on voyait que
Capbreton ils gagnent tous les années
gagner toujours leur match haut la main
ça nous a mis un peu de stress mais on a
continué à jouer et on s'est remis en
moi et alors dans votre équipe du lycée
international de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
il y avait aussi Aurélio italiano un
jeune élève de 5e son rôle et bien était
d'arbitrer les matchs et on l'écoute
tout de suite les compétition pour moi
ça représente
ça représente une chose toute nouvelle
pour moi car je n'ai jamais fait de
compétition de ce type j'ai bien aimé
expérimenté cette compétition car ça
pourra me servir aussi comme comme le
son pour plein d'autres choses et je
remercie encore beaucoup mon professeur
pour m'avoir proposé d'être l'arbitre de
cette équipe qui d'ailleurs est très
forte donc j'ai de la chance Olivier il
y avait des jeunes joueurs mais c'est
important aussi d'avoir les rôles
d'arbitre finalement bah c'est aussi
toutes les facettes du sport qui ont été
présentes pour pour ce trophée c'est une
valeur forte de l'UNSS en fait de
d'intégrer des Jeunes Officiels aux
équipes c'est quelque chose
d'obligatoire d'ailleurs pour nous de
présenter un jeune officiel au même
titre que l'équipe c'est quelqu'un qui
fait partie de l'équipe et c'est je
trouve c'est vraiment génial de voir les
jeunes officiels qui dirigent les
parties nous on est on est mis en
retrait en fait derrière et ils prennent
le relais ils se prennent en main enfin
c'est des jeunes qui sont incroyables
quoi ils nous ils sont bluffants c'est à
dire qu'il a été formé aussi avant la
compétition on l'imagine on a un petit
carnet un petit registre on leur apprend
les règles on leur apprend à se former
puis au fur et à mesure des compétitions
ils acquièrent des compétences des
validations qui sont départementales
académiques pour pouvoir ensuite aller
au championnat de France et puis au
championnat de France il y a une
validation également mais on reliée ici
présent même une validation nationale
qui a pas été donné à tous les arbitres
donc une très très belle réussite c'est
championnats de France Nicolas alors la
finale se joue effectivement contre
Capbreton tu l'as dit Niels c'est une
équipe que tu avais vu bien joué durant
les premiers jours dans quel état
d'esprit tu étais au début de la finale
au début de la finale je me suis je dis
qu'on avait rien à perdre autant tout
tenter et sortir les clubs plus
compliqués à jouer et alors Grégory vous
hésitez pas j'étais sur place sur les
premiers trous ils ont directement pris
le dessus psychologiquement comme vous
voyez les golfeurs de Capbreton et ben
hésiter faire des des coups et qui
partaient en dehors du fairway du coup
c'est là aussi quand vous voyez que les
golfeurs de Capbreton allaient en dehors
de dans les dans les bouches en fait
dans les forêts là dans quel état
d'esprit vous étiez vous dire ah c'est
bien parti
on s'était bien sûr que je pense que
dans notre tête on était tous les deux
très contents parce qu'ils avaient raté
mais aussi
Melvin a été mentalement très très
fort c'était super et je pense que
faut vraiment que il continue comme ça
c'est quoi la suite pour toi Nice
c'était est-ce que tu joues dans un club
aussi en dehors de de la compétition
dans la Bretèche
et j'espère pouvoir partir au
championnat de France cette année
d'accord qu'est-ce qui a fait la
différence oui selon vous Olivier on
parlait du mental dans une finale ou
peut-être le lycée international n'était
pas forcément présenté comme le favori
bon championnat de France là on était
clairement les les deuxièmes au niveau
index donc on était peut-être de série
numéro 2 et je pense qu'on avait rempli
notre rôle on était en allant en finale
après je leur ai dit que tous les coups
que que les adversaires savaient faire
ils savaient également les faire la
seule différence c'était la régularité
et puis un petit peu la niaque donc il
fallait mettre une un petit grain de
sable dans le dans la machine j'ai vu
une île c'est arrivé le matin il dit on
va gagner monsieur on va gagner ça c'est
un bel état d'esprit et effectivement
dès le premier coup il met la balle à 2
mètres du mât on met le pote derrière
pour faire Birdy et tout de suite là ils
se sont mis à doutés dans les
quatre parties du Mardi Mercredi
Capbreton père quatre roues je crois à 4
ou 5 trous au total et nous sur le sur
la finale on gagne 7 trous contre eux
donc c'est on les a fait douter en fait
et eux ils ont fait le ils ont fait le
job les petits c'est bien l'aspect
psychologique a pris le dessus sur cette
finale souvent le cas en golf en sport
souvent j'aurais dit de toute façon en
sport rien n'est écrit il y a un favori
il y a un challenger mais c'est la
beauté du sport en fait de il faut un
gagnant perdant et voilà on a essayé de
se donner les moyens d'être les gagnants
aujourd'hui c'était c'était ça a été le
cas donc bravo bravo Nils mais les
autres aussi font partie de l'Est golf
du lycée international le profil c'est
aussi des jeunes qui pratiquent le golf
en dehors est-ce qu'il y en a qui qui
ont découvert le golf au sein du de
cette US golf il y a clairement deux
profils il y a des des jeunes qui
débutent qui arrivent donc qui qui sont
vraiment débutants et puis des d'autres
qui sont qui sont compétiteurs déjà
aguerris et c'est une des élèves qui qui
arrivait de Suède cette année qui qui
m'informe fasse une équipe au monde ça
donc c'est vraiment elle qui à l'origine
de ça et voilà on a monté ce projet et
puis je pense qu'il y en a eu raison de
de pousser en fait
serait de quoi de jouer un jour une
Ryder Cup on sait qu'il y a aussi
l'année prochaine il y a des Jeux
Olympiques en France alors tu es un peu
jeune aujourd'hui mais peut-être jouer
un jour les Jeux Olympiques en golf ça
t'intéresserait juste mon rêve c'est
devenu de devenir professionnel de golf
le pouvoir vivre ma passion comme mon
métier
avant de clôturer cette séquence déjà
bravo encore une fois bravo lycée
international de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
bravo Olivier bravo à Nils vous voyez
cool clôturer cette séquence avec une
petite séquence juste une image ce pote
magnifique d'un jeune collégien s'il se
reconnaît bravo à lui regarder
voilà pour ce championnat de France de
golf UNSS c'est la victoire on le disait
du lycée international de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye dans la catégorie
Excellence c'est bien ça pour ce trophée
de golf on va ouvrir à présent Nicolas
la page des résultats sport du week-end
et on commence avec du football il y
avait la finale de la Coupe des Yvelines
qui se déroulait ce weekend comme on dit
et un et deux et trois zéro score sans
appel pour la finale de la Coupe des
Yvelines un résultat en faveur
d'Aubergenville FC il affronté ce
dimanche à Maurepas l'équipe de de
Conflans FC Gabriel Gonthier était dans
les tribunes retour sur ce match avec
Mélanie OK
[Musique]
il l'a brandisse fièrement la coupe des
Yvelines et cette année pour eux les
joueurs d'Aubergenville tomber en finale
de l'équipe réserve de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine le score final
3 à 0 une grande fierté une grande
fierté c'est la première fois qu'on
ramène un trophée en tout cas la coupe
des Yvelines seniors à la ville donc en
tout cas nous on est très contents une
première mi-temps accrochée entre les
deux équipes des fautes mais pas de but
en deuxième mi-temps Aubergenville est
enfin libéré le capitaine et président
du club ouvre le score
les aubergins-villois profitent de cette
bonne période en inscrivant deux autres
buts c'est le numéro 12 qui marque 11
minutes ensuite en éliminant défenseur
et gardien le troisième est marqué par
le numéro 8 il est éteint tous les
espoirs de remonter au score pour les
conflamer
[Applaudissements]
ils sont obligés de sortir de se
découvrir donc on arrive à mettre un
deuxième puis un troisième
un peu stressante parce que du coup on
n'arrive pas à marquer on n'arrive pas à
débloquer la situation après une bonne
équipe de Conflans en face de nous voilà
qu'on a su être patient on a su
continuer à mettre notre jeu en place et
en tout cas pour moi c'est une très
grande fierté parce que malgré l'enjeu
on a continué à développer notre jeu
mettre en place qu'on a travaillé toute
l'année donc honnêtement c'est un réel
plaisir face à eux les joueurs de
Conflans 2 sont dans le dur l'équipe ne
parvient pas à s'exprimer plusieurs
blessures ont émaillé le match les
coachs dresse un bilan amer pas mal de
déception
on avait préparé le match comme il
fallait en tout cas on pensait et on a
fait aujourd'hui à nos matchs
que ce soit techniquement tactiquement
ou autre on n'a pas répondu présent et
je m'en excuse auprès des supporters de
Conflans et du club un peu de pression
et on s'est vu un peu trop trop beau je
pense on était pas prêt on n'a pas
l'expérience de jouer ce genre de match
et il faut le prendre comme une bonne
expérience ce type de match même si on a
perdu un titre en coupe mais pas de
monté dans le championnat de première
division pour Aubergenville cette année
c'est donc l'objectif pour la prochaine
saison voir inscrire une deuxième fois
son nom au palmarès de la coupe des
Yvelines
félicitations à Aubergenville il y avait
aussi le deuxième tour de la Coupe de
France de football les clubs amateurs la
débute même la saison avant elle se
poursuivra à partir d'août et des
équipes du niveau départemental et
régional était engagé oui l'objectif
sera de titiller Toulous FC qui l'a
emporté cette année et alors oui Grégory
comme le pour le premier tour retour sur
les scores et bien des communes de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines et dansera que
deux pour le troisième tour trap c'est
imposé 3 à Chaville tout comme
Coignières vainqueur face à Étampes pour
les autres clubs 50 chinois ce deuxième
tour de Coupe de France a été compliqué
Voisins-le-Bretonneux c'est incliné
quatre buts à deux Guyancourt a concéder
la victoire à Saint-Germain Arpajon 3-1
mort pan n'a rien pu faire face à Jouy
le Moutier 6-1 et Élancourt s'est laissé
dominer 3-0 face à Grigny j'espère un
petit poussin qui pourra poursuivre
pourquoi pas le rêve de la Coupe de
France on avait eu Versailles il y a
deux saisons maintenant enfin c'était la
saison dernière qui est qui s'était
tissé jusqu'en demi-finale de la
compétition on va poursuivre du basket
le résultat des phases finales en
Nationale 2 pour Poissy et effectivement
le final fort qui s'est tenu le samedi
10 et dimanche 11 juin à Vannes une
demi-finale qui s'est joué samedi du
coup Poissy c'est incliné 82 à 85 face à
l'Amicale Laïque les données Jura basket
dans l'autre match Montbrison a été
dominé par Avignon pontet et alors pour
la finale et bien ça a été une victoire
pour et bien ceux qui avaient pris le
dessus sur Poissy Lons-le-Saunier et
donc donc décrocher le titre de champion
de France de National 2 cette saison et
donc Poissy et bien a remporté la petite
finale et termine donc de troisième de
National 2 donc on a parlé de basket et
à présent on parle de baseball oui on va
terminer avec cette un résultat de
baseball avec les Cougars de Montigny le
Bretonneux qui pour la 10e journée du
championnat de France de Division 1 et
bien on remporté les deux manches face
au Stade Toulousain et oui le Stade
Toulousain joue aussi au baseball
5-4 lors du premier match 7 1 pour le
deuxième match et au classement les
inondins pointent à la troisième place
du classement vous le saviez il jouait
également en baseball le stade
Toulousains jouaient au baseball
[Musique]
l'équipe faïence des Yvelines qui
représente bien sûr les Yvelines dans
dans ce sport le baseball effectivement
Stade Toulousain grand club de rugby
mais aussi club de baseball on la prend
dans le 7 8 de la gymnastique maintenant
tout à fait avec un événement qui se
déroulait ce weekend c'est ça samedi 10
juin se tenait les finales nationales de
gymnastique UFOLEP au gymnase du Levant
de Fontenay-le-Fleury au complexe
sportif Pierre mazot de
Saint-Cyr-l'École 2000 gymnases étaient
rassemblés pour un objectif le titre de
champion de France le reportage de
Mathilde Franco et Gabriel Gontier
élégance grâce et surtout performance
les enchaînements des athlètes se
succédent avec un objectif s'approcher
de la perfection et pour cause samedi
Fontenay-le-Fleury Saint-Cyr-l'École
accueillez les finales nationales UFOLEP
un enjeu de taille pour les meilleurs
athlètes de France présents pour
remporter le dernier titre de la saison
les champ France ufoley bah c'est la fin
de saison voilà il y a eu trois
compétitions avant les départementaux
les régionaux les demi-finales les
meilleurs sont là c'est le rendez-vous
de fin de saison incontournable que tout
le monde attend qui a été compliqué à
mettre en place cette saison mais voilà
c'est vraiment le gros événement tout ça
vient de partout en France on a à peu
près 2000 gymnastes on a près de 200
clubs qui sont représentés au programme
de cette finale masculine et féminine 6
épreuves pour les garçons parmi elles
seules arceau saut ou encore bar fixe
autant d'agréer aux figures aussi
spectaculaires que maîtrisée
fixe assez plutôt très bien passé sol on
a été un peu surpris par le par le sol
qui est gonflable mais ça c'est quand
même bien passé et puis après arçon on a
fait ce qu'on savait faire et anneau
pareil côté fille 4 agrès barres
asymétriques sol poutre et saut et
chacune c'est spécialités
alors c'est mon agréa du tout on va dire
le sol aussi et la règle j'ai moins
réussi à les barres on est tombé on a
chuté donc forcément
c'est moins bien malgré quelques chutes
et une blessée dans l'équipe cette
compétition reste une fierté pour ses
yvelinoises c'était nos championnats de
France en équipe pour la première fois
donc c'était quand même très sympa
l'occasion de se confronter au meilleur
niveau et d'achever la saison sous les
regards émerveillés du public et
exigeant des juges l'équipe de Lucie et
Céliane terminale à la 7e place de leur
catégorie 12 équipes yvelinoise étaient
engagés elle ramène une médaille d'or
une d'argent et de deux bronze en
individuel 74 athlètes Yvelines ou en
fait le déplacement ils obtiennent deux
médailles d'or et 3 en bronze
rendez-vous l'année prochaine pour de
nouveaux championnats
et à présent dans le 7 8 on parle de
rugby avec un invité du Club Athletic de
Chevreuse cette fois-ci le nom est bon
il s'agit de Stéphane DOUCHET qui est
l'entraîneur de ce club on va revenir
sur cette saison où vous êtes ici
jusqu'au 8e de finale de championnat de
régional une ce qui veut dire vous êtes
aussi vous avez validé dans le même
temps une montée en Fédérale 3 où vous
évoluerez la saison prochaine on va
revenir sur cette saison vous avez
qualifié tout à l'heure de très bonnes
en plus c'était une manière de fêter un
titre anniversaire c'est ça cette saison
tout à fait puisque il y a 20 ans le
club a eu la première étoile donc de
champion de France de première série
voilà donc mais et puis en effet ça fait
c'est une reconstruction un petit peu
qui s'est passé dans dans le club parce
que il y a quelques années quand on
était descendu en première division
régionale on avait vraiment souffert et
là le club se reconstruit petit à petit
avec l'arrivée d'un nouveau président
Dominique Gitter qui a structure très
bien le club et qui amène aussi des
sponsors le à la présidence de l'école
de rugby Marianne Calmels qui fait un
travail remarquable et puis on a le
collège justement nous aussi on a le
collège Pierre Coubertin juste à côté
qui est où il y a une section rugby et
on va on commence en toucher les fruits
enseignants on voit d'ailleurs les
images de votre performance où vous avez
suivi en terrain neutre c'était Tamassi
le 21 mai dernier avec une victoire face
à Créteil 43 à 20 ça c'était pour les
16e de finale de des phases finales de
régionales une et ensuite vous étiez
incliné en 8e de finale d'un seul petit
point face à Saintes au vu de cette
saison qui est qui est très belle est-ce
que cette défaite a pas laissé quand
même un goût amer de perdre d'un seul
point face à Sainte alors l'objectif
principal sportif c'était de monter en
Fédérale 3 c'est atteint mais
franchement c'était pas notre objectif
c'est vu l'équipe qu'on avait
non parce que vraiment on voulait on
voulait un deuxième titre on voulait
quelque chose on voulait et on finit
premier de poule avec 10 points d'avance
un golave rage de plus 600 pour l'équipe
première et on a l'équipe réserve qui a
fini deuxième aussi et l'équipe réserve
qui allait quand même en quart de finale
avec du championnat de France contre
Bourg-en-Bresse donc on a plus de on a
80 joueurs dans l'effectif on a bon
l'effet le s'appelle l'objectif sportif
il est un minimum cette année nous
espériez mieux ah oui vraiment vous
voulez un titre et bon là pas on est
déçu là dessus parce qu'on est
compétiteur quoi donc je peux vous dire
Grégory lors de la victoire face à
Créteil amassi Stéphane DOUCHET tu es
vraiment pas content de son équipe vous
êtes un peu un entraîneur
perfectionniste vous attendez beaucoup
de vos joueurs qui qui jouent qui
gagnent mais avec la manière aussi
on est là aussi pour on était encore en
phase je veux dire pour progresser on
était en chemin et c'est pour ça que le
chemin s'arrête si tôt pour l'équipe
première non c'était vraiment non on
n'était pas content mais d'un autre côté
c'est pas grave parce que il y a
plusieurs joueurs cadres qui nous
avaient dit bon on va pas rester
longtemps on va juste venir et ben ils
ont dit on reste et l'année prochaine on
recommence et on casse tout en Fédérale
3 mais sur quoi ne n'étiez pas
uniez-vous pas content sur un quand même
23 points d'avance face à Créteil à 40
43 ans on commence par au bout d'un
quart d'heure on était mené 17-0 voilà
donc vous avez fait une remontée comme
La Rochelle finalement c'était la veille
La Rochelle Lanester c'était la veille
d'inspirer vos joueurs il y a des
crapuls lui je me doute bien avec on
fait ça oui mais non on s'est pas fait
peur on n'a pas eu peur du tout parce
qu'on les avait déjà joué Créteil en
phase avant en championnat et on avait
gagné déjà de 50 points donc on savait
qu'on avait une marge avec eux voilà
faut revenir aussi sur quelque chose
peut-être une défaite qui est qui est
amère aussi pour vous c'est c'est la
finale de régionale une Île-de-France
parce que le régionale une ça d'abord ça
se passe au niveau régional et ensuite
on bascule sur un championnat de France
avec les meilleurs les finalistes c'est
ça
3 il y avait trois clubs par poules
c'était voilà qui bascule sur un
championnat de France et vous avez
concédé la défaite en finale face à
Paris XO ça c'est mal passé aussi les
joueurs m'en ont parlé d'ailleurs à la
fin de la rencontre de ce 16e de finale
face à Créteil bah oui parce que Paris
XO a fini à 10 dans la saison régulière
a fini 10 points derrière nous et quand
ils sont venus jouer chez nous on leur a
on leur a sans vouloir leur manquer de
respect on leur a quand même 1050 points
quoi donc ils sont venus chez nous 1050
points puis quand les a rejoués là bah
peut-être qu'il y avait un excès de
confiance et donc on a perdu donc on a
perdu deux matchs comme ça peut-être par
excès de confiance par peut-être me
manque de travail ou en tout cas c'était
on n'est pas content de ces deux matchs
perdus quoi donc objectif sportif à
minima monter en Fédérale 3 ou vous
évoluerez je le disais la saison
prochaine le travail on imagine a déjà
commencé là les joueurs sont sont en
vacances maintenant comment ça va se
passer d'ici le début de cette nouvelle
saison oui alors là pour l'instant les
joueurs sont en vacances il y a pas de
souci alors on finit on s'entraîne tout
le temps nous aussi il y a du monde qui
veut venir le mardi le jeudi on continue
de s'entraîner et c'est peut-être le
travail en coulisse qui s'opère mais
alors justement il y a du travail en
coulisses pour garder au maximum de
joueurs pour en faire venir d'autres
pour amener des sponsors parce qu'on
cherche je voyais tout à l'heure il y
avait un forum des des entreprises on
est preneur et nous des entreprises qui
veulent participer à être accompagné les
valeurs du rugby dans leur entreprise on
nous on peut les on peut les aider et
puis peuvent nous aider parce qu'on
arrive en fédéral et en fédéral on a
besoin en effet de de sponsors d'un
budget plus important mais
pour l'instant ça se passe bien on est
en route et on augmente notre staff
technique avec notamment
conservation d'un joueur comme au bain
Mendes qui va être entraîneur entraîneur
joueur l'année prochaine qui joue en Pro
D2 justement à Massy et puis on
renforce avec la une salle de
musculation disponible pour les joueurs
on passe à trois entraînements avec des
entraînements individualisés donc on
fait en sorte que de pouvoir se mettre
au niveau rapidement et ça c'est le
niveau fédéral 3 on le sait aujourd'hui
même maintenant c'est plus fédéral 3
c'est fédéral 2 les clubs comme
Versailles comme MLS GP cette saison qui
a qui monte pour la saison prochaine en
Fédérale 2 et puis plaisir bien
évidemment ont déjà ce système là
l'objectif c'est d'aller viser justement
de rejoindre peut-être la mlsvp le mlsvp
Versailles et plaisir en Fédérale 2
peut-être ou peut-être étape par étape
bien sûr alors on va faire étape par
étape on va pas tout griller d'un coup
mais en effet l'année prochaine
l'objectif pour nous il sera pas le
maintien l'objectif ce sera déjà de se
qualifier pour le match de barrage au
moins pour le match de barrage donc une
cinq ou sixième place et ensuite on
verra bien ce sera du bonus cette année
on était favoris on a perdu l'année
prochaine on va se mettre en mode soldat
et puis on en surprendra beaucoup quoi
et dans votre eau vous avez beaucoup de
joueurs des Yvelines ou c'est des gens
du cru principalement on a énormément de
de gens du cru justement parce que
Chevreuse donc il y a 5500 et habitants
mais l'école de rugby est vraiment une
institution et beaucoup de joueurs là
sont revenus ils étaient partis à dans
faire carrière comme à Massy ou même à
d'autres dans d'autres clubs et là ils
sont revenus au club pour essayer de
justement faire progresser le club voilà
et il y a une grosse école de rugby à
Chevreuse même avec des interventions
dans les écoles du club voilà on
pratique le rugby au lycée international
il y a une balise rugby en troisième
Seconde Première terminale avec une
grosse section fille d'ailleurs qui fait
très fort qui est championne d'académie
aussi donc c'est rugby à 7 mais une
grosse culture rugby qui pêcher on
préfère le rugby au foot chez nous mais
voilà ça c'est l'autre vous êtes
pardonné Nil c'est ce que vous aimez le
rugby ou à côté du golf pas d'autres
sports je suis un peu de tennis en
dehors du golf mais le rugby quand on a
fait une session en sport c'était
magnifique j'ai bien aimé ce sport avec
une belle saison plus pour le rugby
français cette année deux titres de
Coupe d'Europe Nicolas ou si vous avez
une petite dernière question est-ce que
vous justement final de Top 14 ce
week-end mais surtout au mois de
septembre et jusqu'en fin octobre la
Coupe du monde de rugby en France est-ce
que vous attendez un effet coupe du
monde dans la vallée de Chevreuse alors
on espère en effet que va y avoir un
phénomène d'aspiration et que ça va nous
gonfler nos effectifs parce que les
effectifs d'aujourd'hui ont chez les
jeunes seront les effectifs de dans
quelques années chez les seniors et en
effet on espère que les résultats de
l'équipe de France qui n'ont pas douté
sont excellents déjà dès le premier
match contre la Nouvelle-Zélande ça sera
excellent on donnera le thème pour tout
de suite et on espère que ça va nous
apporter énormément de moi beaucoup de
joueurs et puis
les valeurs du rugby vont en effet
continuer de s'implanter dans notre
société merci beaucoup Sté doucher
entraîneur du club athlétique de
Chevreuse bravo pour la montée même si
c'est un objectif au minima il y a quand
même une montée à fêter pour Chevreuse
en Fédérale 3 et on aura l'occasion bien
sûr de suivre la saison prochaine les
performances de vos joueurs dans ce
championnat de Fédérale 3 avant de
terminer cette partie sport Nicolas une
dernière information handball que vous
voulez nous relayer oui un rendez-vous
ce weekend les 16 17 et 18 juin se
tiendront bah elle est finalité de
handball la coupe challenge des Yvelines
qui se tiendra au Palais des Sports
d'Élancourt voilà c'était un événement
organisé par le comité départemental des
Yvelines de handball sur trois jours et
plusieurs finales effectivement pour ces
finalités de handball merci beaucoup
Nicolas c'est bientôt la fin de ce 7 8
mais on va jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
[Musique]
après le temps orageux de ces derniers
jours le soleil et le ciel clair le ciel
clair qui reviennent demain il va faire
chaud et dès le matin comptez 19 degrés
à Mantes-la-Jolie 18 à Houdan et
Rambouillet même 20 degrés à Versailles
l'après-midi les conditions n'évoluent
pas les températures sont proches des 30
degrés il fera 29 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 28 sur les secteurs de
Versailles ou dans et Rambouillet voilà
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci d'avoir été
avec nous vous avez rendez-vous demain
avec Mathilde Franco pour une nouvelle
édition de cette émission belle soirée
sur TV 78
[Musique]